let's hear Trump himself on the charges
[Applause]
an insult to our country as the world is
already laughing at us
for so many other reasons like our open
borders
are incompetent withdrawal from
Afghanistan Where We Left Behind
American citizens 85 billion dollars
worth of
the best military equipment in the world
lost 13 magnificent young lives and far
too many
to mention that are so badly hurt with
the loss of arms and legs and facial
obliteration
the most embarrassing time in our
country's history in my opinion
they want to settle the case but I want
no part of that
[Applause]
you know Jeffrey to to John's point
there you know he basically read the
entire speech right he didn't have his
crazy off-the-cuff moment the energy
seemed a little low and maybe that
really is part of it they feel that they
can just kind of grind him down long
enough flying to New York that day and
back give the speech 76 years old let's
roll this for a year and a half and and
the magic of what Trump is that I think
probably you know attracted half of the
country at least at one time to him
would would sort of dwindle yeah
um I didn't think the speech was so bad
what I what I was intrigued by most with
that Soliloquy is his his March uh
through his own victimization right so
he goes through the Russia hoax and the
Ukraine thing and then uh uh you know he
marched ahead to the uh to the ballot
controversies around the uh and then and
then the FBI rate of his headquarters
went through everything there was a
glaring hole in his narrative and it can
concerned everything that happened
between March 10th and and and and his
and the election which were the coveted
lockdowns which he is subject and then
warp speed subjects he does not want to
talk about it either everybody knows
that Mar-A-Lago never bring this up and
yet that was the most mental momentous
attack on on on the western conception
of Rights and Liberties uh probably
since the Magna Carta and you've looked
you've come to consider the scale I mean
three years ago this weekend we weren't
allowed to go to church that was I'm
sorry a trump greenlighted that so now
he wants us to forget about it I mean
he's forgotten about it therefore it
doesn't matter you know the country was
in shambles by the time November arrived
and he wanted to just pretended it
didn't even matter so that's what stood
out to me that speech was not so much
what he said but what he didn't say so
to me uh he's he's part of this whole
plot to memory hole this is astonishing
catastrophe and pretend like he had
nothing to do with it yeah
John bring us home on this one I suspect
Us in Florida are not going to let this
thing be memory hold because it because
it was done right here it's why I moved
here and and you were here far longer
than I was
yeah I mean look I'm with Jeffrey on
this one I'll I'll make it a little more
succinct Trump's 2016 message was
optimistic right it was it was look at
my life I'm wealthy I'm famous you can
live like me let's make America great
again let's restore the American dream
you can live like me Trump's 2023 24
messages oh my God my life is in
shambles give me money help me pay my
legal bills look what they're doing to
me woe is me I'm the victim that's not a
winning optimistic message by any
stretch of the imagination if you'd like
more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell